make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so we are picking up with the boys
and and here's the thing technically the
the next story that takes place after
the one that we just did is called the
self-preservation Society but what I
want to do is I want to sidetrack that
for a second and I want to go over this
origin of mothers milk and the reason
why is because we can kind of do this
right the origin of mother's milk it
doesn't really take place alongside
anything it's just a totally
self-contained story so it's not like
we're really missing anything by not
covering the self preservation to
society who did that in the next video
but a lot of the guys have really
expressed a lot of curiosity about
mothers milk especially why they call
him that and and so on
that's all thought I'd be kind of fun to
go ahead and cover this and so what this
does is this initially picks up on a
bridge with Mother's Milk speaking to
Huey and this is one of the cool things
because what he does is really start to
spill the beans about his life and this
is kind of a cool thing because the
reality is that over the course of the
boys series so far while he's been
fighting alongside them for the most
part he doesn't know anything about them
and it's something that didn't really
occur to me until we got to this story
this is kind of interesting he doesn't
really know the origin of any of the
members of the of the boys right he
doesn't really know how they all met he
doesn't know how they all got started
all he knows is that there was a guy
named Mallory that kind of that seemed
to essentially unite them at some point
in the past and then everything with the
boys first outing in terms of their
crusade all went belly up and now this
is the second the second kind of coming
together of the team as well as a cool
idea because what you end up doing is is
picking up with mother's milk
essentially talking about his youthful
days and what he says is that when he
was younger when he was a little baby of
course like any child he was nursed by
his mother the problem with this or the
difference here is that under normal
circumstances you know eventually you're
weaned off of nursing right and then
eventually you start to get into the
process where you start eating solid
foods different things like that that
kind of graduates you into being a child
where you're just eating like your peas
and you're you know so on and so forth
it and doing what you're supposed to do
for a mother's milk that didn't happen
instead what ended up taking place here
is that when the attempt was made to
wean him off breast milk that he started
to sort of shrivel up and become
exceedingly weak and so this was done
about two or three times the first time
it was kinda like okay we're not really
sure what's going on and so he started
nursing again and he was right back to
being as good as he ever was and then
the attempt was made to nurse him off
the second time and the exact same thing
happened he ended up shriveling up each
time there was an attempt made to nurse
him off he he came closer and closer to
dying and so eventually his mother
started to realize it
order for Mother's Milk to continue
thriving that he has to basically nurse
her like yes - yes - consumer breast
milk and that's why they call him
mother's milk is because in order for
him to continue living he constantly has
to consume the breast milk of his mother
now this is an interesting thing because
one it's kind of a darker tone with
regards to how a superhero functions but
- it puts a shelf life on and the reason
why is because you know in in reality a
mother can only nurse for so long and
then her breast will stop producing milk
which really kind of begs the question
how was she producing so much we'll
actually find out an answer to that
question here in a little while but the
other part is once she's dead and gone
assuming there's no surplus of her
breast milk stored up somewhere he's
gonna die so basically he'll die earlier
than pretty much everybody else at least
that seems to be the case and so as a
result of that the reality of him
nursing from his mom at this is an old
age more or less you know having
supposed to have been graduated off of
that was a secret that was kind of kept
by him his mother and his father but his
brother Michael never knew right he was
never told he was something that was
kind of kept very close in at one point
la la la and his mother worked at a
factory the problem was that this
factory was owned by flawed American and
during this point in time this is you
know produce section of this factory
basically it was designed to can things
uh was essentially used by bought
American as a means to like experiment
and try to create superheroes what this
meant was that compound V the substance
that creates superheroes in the boys
series had basically permeated this
entire place it infected the water
supply and affected the air the whole
nine yards the problem is that bought
American being a corporation did what
corporations do and it cut corners it
didn't tell anybody about that or
anything along those lines because it
like most corporations it doesn't really
concern itself with the goings-on of
people it's just interested in making
money and so as a result of that but
what you ended up having was all these
different women who were infected like
three hundred some-odd women who were
working in this factory who were
infected with compound V of all the
women who were infected only a few of
them actually ended up going forward
without any ill side of that right the
mother of mothers milk was infected but
she basically ended up passing that on
to him and his brother and of course
that's why he has to nurse for all the
other mothers who were there they
develop things like cancer right their
organs sort of shrinking up and going
away they're experiencing these horrific
horrific side effects basically their
bodies were literally falling apart and
that's why the substance is so
incredibly dangerous because even though
it's used by fought American to
basically be fed to
two babies in order to attempt to
develop superpowers the possible side
effects and what came what can happen
there usually outweigh the possible
successes despite the fact that is
refined despite the fact that is this
perfected it could still cause all kinds
of problems when you look at that
refined version of compound V and then
you in turn talk about these three
hundred some-odd women and god only
knows how many others who were exposed
to an unrefined version well god only
knows what kind of effects it was going
to have and ultimately ended up killing
most of them and so as a result of that
and what you ended up having was was the
father of mother's milk who was brought
into the equation but at the time he was
basically busted for selling weed and
you know it seems like some Columbia
professor he was thrown in jail for a
pretty significant amount of time
ultimately he only served four years
because of the fact that he educated
himself and then basically lost his own
appeal as well as result of that he was
he was basically you know only given a
four year sentence and then he
ultimately ended up meeting the mom of
mothers milk and so following that his
father basically went forward and said
we have to find a way to hold vaud
american accountable for what is it
they've done now here's the interesting
thing behind this and it's a tactic that
a lot of exceedingly wealthy people or
corporations used the reality is that
when the average Joe decided to file a
lawsuit essentially on their own against
some major corporations all the
corporation really has to do is wait
them out right now all they have to do
is just basically say what we need to
continue it to you and just keep filing
and filing and filing so that eventually
the person filing the lawsuit all their
money runs out and so they can't
continue their case anymore and usually
that's much cheaper than a payoff and
usually places do that because they're
guilty and they know you know if it went
in front of a jury whether it's because
this person fought in the lawsuit was
pulling at the jury's heartstrings or
whatever the case is the corporation
would ultimately be found at fault and
they would have to pay out a lot more
than they would if they just basically
stretched this person out and called it
a day
that's why class-action lawsuits are so
effective because suddenly you have a
lot of people contributing to a legal
case and so because you have all this
money you kind of falling into the case
itself it starts to pick up a lot of
attention from the press different
things like that and so the result is
very difficult for a corporation to kind
of push them out instead corporations
kind of have to go forward with this
suit and then try to prepare the best
defense they can and then the legal
system determines the rest the issue
with this is that for the father of
mothers milk a lot of the women out
there a lot of the individuals who have
been impacted by this unintentional
consumption of the unrefined version of
compound beef we're either too far gone
to be able to do anything meaning their
bodies are too far falling apart maybe
their minds were gone they've kind of
gone insane and they developed Alzheimer
or
or something like that others were too
scared some just couldn't afford it it
ended up really just being mother's
milks father you know he was one of the
only one who was able to do anything
with this at the same time while he did
hire a lawyer the lawyer wasn't really
the best right he really couldn't afford
a super high-end lawyer and that's the
reason why the father ended up doing
most of the work on his own and so
eventually after like eight or nine
attempts to basically bring this to
court and to have a judge preside over
it ultimately he ended up being
successful that payout was not
substantial right it's not like he got
like millions and millions and millions
and millions of dollars in reality it
was a drop of the Hat for Vaughn
American there was really nothing there
but notice this this is what really set
in motion the absolute hatred that
Mother's know Kaiser bought American in
so far asked when the lawyers were
leaving it was like well you win some
you lose some
then in reality like people's entire
lives had been destroyed and turned
upside down but for what American it was
like well you went some court cases you
lose some court cases and that was it
they didn't really care it didn't matter
to them and that's what really struck a
chord with Mother's Milk is the complete
lack of concern for the average
individual on behalf of a corporation so
long as the the financial loss they
sustained was not like you know
detrimental then who cares what happened
to these people
and so as a result of that this began
the process now it wasn't really the
tipping point the tipping point that
came with this rule II came by wave his
brother Michael and the reason why was
because with with mothers on Mother's
Milk smother being infected with
compound V this was passed on to both
mother's milk and his brother Mike and
so ultimately Michael's powers ended up
manifesting but they ended up doing that
when he was wearing his football helmet
playing outside on the street and
because he started growing so
astronomically fast because of compound
beef he basically grew to the point
where literally his helmet essentially
crushed his head and ended up killing
him and so his brother basically died
and so as a result of that the father of
mothers milk went back in and said okay
let's get back to work again the problem
with this he didn't really have the
heart for it anymore the judicial system
is a very slow in a very screwed up
system insofar as it basically takes
forever to get anything done right as a
system it's really designed to not
benefit the average American and so
because of that and when you have a
scenario like this unfolding you're
talking about the exceedingly wealthy
who are able to gain the system versus
the smaller guy who's not and so what
this meant was that going back into
court again with no real light at the
end of the tongue right like no
guarantee he would even be successful
especially when you're talking about you
know all these multiple illnesses versus
the son
of a guy dying this basically caused him
to have a heart attack and he ended up
dying he ended up just basically passing
away tits desk on top of all that the
mother of mothers milk was already
struggling why she was dealing with
depression she's dealing with all these
these major issues she'd lost her
husband she lost one of her sons she
didn't really have a desire to keep
going anymore and where Mother's Milk
had tried the best he could were to
bring somebody on board that could take
care of her ultimately she is simply
just kind of given up you know she just
sort of just walked away from it all
because the life that she lived it to
this point had taken so much out of her
and so as results that what you ended up
how do as Mother's know basically saying
okay then Vaughn Americans gonna have to
find a way to pay and if we can't make
Vaughn American paid the legal system
then we'll use unconventional means and
so following that this is ultimately
when Mother's Milk ended up joining the
military and it's kind of a crazy thing
because he was joining the military and
you know engaged these various fights
different things like that
it's one of these scenarios where he
essentially joined the army because it
was the only real way for him to make
money that in turn could pay off a lot
of the debts that his mother owed but
the funny thing about this is that in
the middle of this boxing match suddenly
his powers manifest and when they do
he literally punches the guy's head off
he uppercuts like he goes straight up
Johnny Cage and just uppercuts this
guy's head off which is absolutely
bonkers because of course you know
regardless of whether whether or not it
was intentional he killed somebody here
so that means he is now come like he's
he's out of the military right he's out
of the army the funny thing is that this
is when Billy butcher comes in now
remember this seems to be in the
original iteration of the boys
especially because we have Mallory here
who's basically the one leading the team
remember he read that he led the
original variation of the boys and so
what this does is it brings in Billy
butch who basically says I've looked
over your entire life in your entire
file and we're mother's note initially
looks at this as a guy who's basically
screwing with him speaking ill of his
mother and and so on and so forth the
reality of what Billy butcher is
presenting here is I have a way for you
to be able to get revenge that you've
wanted right like you want von American
to pay bond American is is essentially
using the system that was designed to
benefit them against you and your family
so I can help you skirt all that and
basically get the justice you deserve
without having to worry about all the
nonsensical nature of the judicial
system right without having to worry
about like courts and things like that
which are trying to impede your progress
and so as a result of that he officially
ends up joining Billy butcher and
ultimately becomes part of the boys and
so following that what you get is the
scenario where Billy butcher does
same thing you do with Huy right and
it's one of the things that Billy wisher
does insofar as it's one thing to come
along and to say hey I can help you make
your life better right like I can help
you get what it is that you want to want
to want to achieve you have to believe
me
and then actually implementing a good
faith effort and that's really what this
is right this is an act in good faith of
Billy butcher basically telling you
Mother's Milk we can track down your
wife and your child you know such things
like we can we can track down what's
going on with these two people that you
haven't really been able to find and so
it gets kind of nuts because with
mothers know joining up with Billy as
well as Malorie and going on this
crusade against fought American what he
began to realize was the same thing that
he realized that nothing he believed
about superheroes was true that you had
superheroes who were engaging in these
insane actions of debauchery and all
kinds of nonsensical stuff and so with
that in mind he really didn't feel any
remorse towards taking these superheroes
out that in his mind bought American had
engineered this circumstance whereby
people were given incredible power and
then given no real oversight the only
rule they were given was don't do
anything that disrupts the flow of money
and so what what does it really kind of
page a darker picture of people that if
you put people in a circumstance where
they can do or say pretty much anything
they want to with no recourse to their
actions whatsoever they will bend to
their darker sides they were basically
bitten down and become the worst version
of themselves following that that goes
into the whole incident of the Brooklyn
Bridge this is like 9/11 more or less as
a wind now now we talked about that in
the previous videos right 9/11 was going
down and and as a result of that bought
American or at least the vice-president
ended up stepping in when he knocked out
the President of the United States and
said call off the planes disallowed
bought American to interview to bring
their superheroes in the seven who ended
up screwing up the entire situation and
taking out a bridge Mother's Milk was
there during the whole thing right so
what he saw here was not the act of
terrorists what he saw here was the
negligence of vaud American davonne
American this kind of through their
superheroes in there with no training
whatsoever they were painfully
ill-equipped for that they had no
business doing that and so what it meant
was that there was mass casualty here
right like reaching out to a woman who
was screaming about her children and
this woman basically being ripped in
half by attention lines was a horrifying
situation but looking at that and and
looking at the situation is saying all
this could have been averted had've on
american been stopped in the past so
they've been kept from being allowed to
operate without any kind of purview
whatsoever if they were if they were
brought down then things while they
necessarily be the best thing ever it
would certainly make the world a better
place but that's the whole idea behind
Mother's know that's the origin of his
story it's amazing right it's really
really cool it's dark but it's really
really cool but without that you said
you guys we're gonna bring this video to
an end if you are new here to comments
explain make sure you guys with the sub
button to become part of the Rob port if
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and I will catch you all
later peace